好的 然後我覺得這樣子
今天我們把那個從其實去年年底開始
我們其實說到過就是整個市場經濟上有很大的這個
我覺得這個底線很高
然後風險很大 那個時候是這麼說的
我覺得幾個風險點吧
因為一直講到會有tell risk 很大的風險點
那麼我們把這些東西重新過一點
就是對於當時的一個判斷的回顧
然後掌握一下我們覺得未來會怎麼樣
就首先回到那個請求以前吧
當然是在12月份的時候
12月份的時候我們當時講到過有三個風險
一個是關稅 budget cut 就是降低他的這個
就是美國降低支出
然後移民的法案
然後還有就是歐洲和中國
那個光說歐洲的話
其實不完全概括就是出美國之外的經濟體
發生問題
就是歐洲和中國
那你現在我們來回顧這三件事情的話
就是這一周其實市場有好幾個美國的立法
包括這個移民這一邊
其實出了一個dignity act
那個dignity act基本上是說
2020年以後的新的移民
那這個是兩黨一起通過的一個東西
所以其實是一個折中的方案
就相當於給到2020年以前的這些人
有居住在美國
沒有辦法獲得美國身份
但是他可以繼續去工作
就交過七千塊錢
交過七千塊錢
有交過稅
那麼你就可以繼續待在美國
其實市場不光當時是擔心
就是說去年有很多的新移民進來
然後今年可能只有50萬到70萬
其實市場還是很擔心
當時我也很擔心
就是當中川普當政之後
他有可能會對移民採取更強硬的手段
然後不光是說今年移民少
而且有可能讓原來的移民
不一定敢去工作
那這是一個比較大的問題
那麼對於拜登時期
就上一任政府時期
進來那些移民怎麼解決
他是不是還會有被dipotation
被淺送回去
或者他因為怕被淺送
他不敢出來工作
那麼減少勞工的人數
然後減少
就相應的話就是會減少增加通脹
然後減少GDP
那麼會有這個風險
但是至少對於2020年前的人
有一個比較明確的說法
其實我是感覺
因為市場其實一直在吹的插口
包括4月份以來
那個整個市場吹的插口
大家沒有
你看當中川普最近出了很多事情
包括他對於那個
對於FOD
對於JPOW
對於他們的這些言論
然後美國最近又開始威脅
自己的幾個盟友
包括歐洲在內
那麼他們要增加關稅
其實市場都沒有
他把他當回事情
其實市場本
本質上在吹插口
就覺得川普你說的話
跟方幣沒有取別
就是包括你對移民政策
包括你對於我們之前說deficit
大家之前不是搞了個doge嗎
減少那個減少赤字
那其實他那個赤字跟
我們說雖然說他的
我們叫做GDP除以
就是deficit除以GDP
他變小了那麼一點點
基本上沒變
但是deficit
就是整個債務的規模
還是在繼續擴張的
所以我們會看到這些事情上
他其實都沒有敢
真的動盪動強
包括甚至移民上面
他砍的最兇的
他最要去拉馬卡票的是移民
但是現在看來
也是相當於說比較折衷的一個法案
那麼我覺得這三個
就是美國本地的就是
我們叫關稅
然後減赤字和移民這三件事情
移民會有持續性的影響
那至少他不像去年和前年這樣
一直有新的移民進來
壓低他的通脹
然後增加他的增長
那這個沒有一個正面的因素
但是看上去不會造成很大的
負面的影響
就是說把原來移民要趕走
或者非常強硬的手段
發生催斷式的這個
我們叫做tell risk
為不風險
但這種事情可能現在看上去
概率沒有那麼的大
budget card這件事情
大家討論過很多了
就是我們看到最近的
大美利潘通過之後
我覺得這個風險基本上是移除掉
現在在美國本身的話
還是關稅
就是關稅這個事情
我們看到他在上一周的
這個經濟數據上面
那個通脹數據沒有很難看
通脹數據沒有特別難看
CPI的話還是比預期的要低
但是你要看CPI分類的話
其實CPI分類並沒有那麼好
就是你會看到其實商品的價格
再上升
就是我們看到tell risk
就是關稅的影響發生了
但是同時的話
就除了商品以外
包括房租和公司這些東西
沒有上升
就房租還在下降
是房租其實是一個有趨勢性的東西
我們在一年以前
我記得我們一年多以前
一直講到通脹有影響
通脹回頭
當時上升的是房租
房租延續性的上升
我們當時就講到
房租這東西是有18個月的之後的
所以你看到它的當時的上升
其實並不是真正的上升
所以通脹我們覺得是可空
後面會一直可空
這是我大概一年多以前
也講過這個事情
那麼我覺得現在同樣
就是說現在這個趨勢是下降
所以你即使有一些通脹的因素
這個因素更多的是
我們說關稅引起的是one off的
一次性的
所以會有影響
但是不太影響
工資不太影響房租
這個事情我大法會結合
包括中國現在消費
或者是我們中國現在的ZPR的情況
你起來說一下
所以我覺得在聯儲內部
就是美國政策指定方內部
也有同樣的這個問題
就是說
我們聯儲可能也會覺得
這個通脹是一次性
它會影響美聯儲現在降息的決策
因為確實現在沒有必要去做這個事情
就是那個沒有緊迫感美聯儲
但是呢
不太會讓聯儲就是會變得長期的非常強硬
這個是一個情況
那麼特朗普上兩週的時候
對於接票大打出手
因為他非常希望把接票幹掉
那麼我覺得幹掉的原因
不光是說
那個接票的政策和特朗普不一樣
因為接票在特朗普面子上說是
相當於美聯儲比較強硬
他不肯降息
所以導致國家制止增加
那其實可能是因為
接票在上一次聯儲會議的時候
明確的表達
就是我們現在為什麼不降息
然後我們現在為什麼有通脹
是因為我們總統採取的關稅的政策
這惹惱了特朗普
他對權力和對於自己的面子
其實看了比什麼都重要
所以他用這個原因去攻擊了接票
而且他攻擊的原因是說
美聯儲大事要裝修花了太多的錢
所以你們預算超之辣
你們裝修很貴
然後中間有毛泥
用這個原因希望把接票幹掉
然後或者是把他辭職
那上一周前幾天他又打口了
就是他又說白宮又說沒有這個意圖
因為白宮沒有辦法直接用
就是因為美聯儲不是一個department
所以白宮不能夠隨便把聯儲主席給解僱掉
央行主席不能隨便他要獨立一些
那麼不能因為政策員解僱他
那麼他其實想用其他的方法
但是弄了一半之後他又收手了
所以其實市場是對於聯儲
對於那個Donald Trump做出的各種政策
其實都是不太把黨回事
就是他嘴巴大把他當成說一說就好
那麼我說一下
因為不過Anyone那個接票都是會在明年卸任
所以明年卸任以後
如果上來一個特朗普的粉絲
就是或他的他比較喜歡的人
那個政策跟他相同的
會不會讓美聯儲大規模的降息呢
我覺得也是不太會
因為關稅的影響現在開始顯露出來
我是覺得在三季度四季度的時候
還是會比較有明顯的這個反應
那麼這個事情我們應該上兩周
忘了是在哪裡
就是上兩周可能我們講過這個問題
就是我有點沒找到那個ppd
就是我們看兩個指標吧
第一個指標就是從訂口的商品上來看
明確的這個價格在上升的
第二個就是公司對於有多少的意願
應該是兩三個星期前
公司有多少的意願把這個價格轉遞到消費者頭上
那麼Business survey
那麼這個Business survey中間大概有3個月裡50%
然後6個月以上80%到90%
所以現在並沒有轉移大部分的這個價格
到消費者頭上
所以CPI確實是有時間的間隔
就是有GAM的時間
然後這個關稅的影響是會導致這個CPI上升
這是從我的角度來上來看
那麼只是說我們現在看到的Tariff的影響
確實比2019年中美貿易戰的時候要小
這個中間有各方面的原因了
但是也影響看上去會比較小
但是如果我們回到12月份的時候的那些
就是我們看到的這個市場風險的話
我是覺得Tariff的影響大頭其實差不多過去了
上兩周它對於歐洲提出
提出要加30%的關稅這些事情
那麼這些關稅的影響
其實我覺得其實也是一種踏口
因為本身的Sectorbase就是我們叫做這個行業性的關稅
它加了比方說同50%
對吧
理論上行業性的對於兩個重要的行業
第一個是藥品
第二個是半導體
它都要在比方說在那個今年夏天
或者是今年年底之前
理論上都要推出關稅
但是因為有中期權權
所以推出藥品的這個關稅
其實是個非常敏感的事情
那就因為這個直接抬高了很多醫療的成本
它不一定非常敢去幹這個事情
它需要去做關稅
它的另外一地方洩洪了
那麼同樣的話
半導體上
它我現在覺得Basecase還是會推
就是Sector行業性的關稅還是會推
但是我覺得也有種說法
就是它現在也有點踏口
對於半導體上
因為半導體100%的全世界半導體都是台灣造的
除了那些DUV造的低端性便宜外
你說比方說注重卡這些
中國也可以造
就是低端的被中國捲得很兇
但是只要是DUV的
現在大家用的都是台積電的卡
那麼它到底對半導體加稅這件事情
到最後會怎麼樣
不太好說
所以在關稅上面
我覺得最壞的時期
就是它的政策偏一度最高
最壞的時期可能過掉了
但是關稅的影響會在今年年底
或者是明年發生
就是我們看到整個經濟體
和去年年底的時候的判斷
其實確實有點不一樣
去年年底是覺得底線很高
就整個市場非常好
底線很高
經濟很好
然後有這麼多的不確定性
市場會有很大的風險
那現在來看的底線並沒有去年這麼高
因為關稅的影響
基本面會變差一點
但是從半導體來說
我當然會說一下半導體
本質上底線很好
就是這個半導體很好
或者是我們叫做科技公司
科技公司的盈利
加上半導體的需求
半導體公司的盈利
這個是我在過去這麼長時間
一直堅持的說
就是它就是很好
就不太會有影響
那麼整體市場估值是不是很高
確實我覺得在衝破性高之後
衝破性高有兩個原因
但是一方面是市場
一方面是technical
就是技術上
一方面是這個公司本身的盈利導致
那麼在這個情況下
現在估值確實比較高
但是tell risk顯著的下降
現在來看
就是我不覺得
川普的政府會再採取這些政策
就是很極端的催斷性的政策
像那個
像4月份這種催斷型的政策
不太會
那麼Tariff的影響
會拉低的是底線基本面
而不是產生催斷
因為可測性變高了
就是它說什麼樣的話
本質上它最後還是會tackle
那回過來說歐洲和中國的風險
就是歐洲的風險
我覺得比去年判斷要好很多
因為歐洲在基本面再查
德國的確定性的支出在哪裡
就是它確實有大規模支出
大家也在炒作這個支出
那麼但是
我們說整個資本市場上來看
美國的資本市場
和比較rest of world
全世界其他地方
這是兩個不同的資本市場
就是美國的資本市場是有科技帶動的
然後我們叫US exceptionism
當你說到AI和未來的科技和增長
那你只能談到是美國
那中國和歐洲都不存在
包括現在都是不可能存在的
就科技上面是沒有的
就是你如果談到AI
那只有在美國
包括以後的雲酸里
這些新的東西都在美國
但是歐洲和中國
正在經歷一個估值的成功
我們去年也說到過
就是說Telrescu是有
微步風險是有往上和往下的
在歐洲和中國
可能會產生往上的微步風險
就是它暴漲
但是這個暴漲可能是短期的
因為它確實沒有exceptionism
沒有就是區別度
就是在美國這種區別度
美國資本市場的區別度
就是它在於公司的營利
在於它高科技
在於它對於未來的
就是你會覺得它有很強的
有dream
有未來的這個有夢想
對吧
那麼中國和歐洲是估值的一個修復
然後對於政府支出的
對於政府支出的一個憧憬
那麼在歐洲確實風險會小很多
所以這四個方面就是風險
確實都小不少
那中國另外
中國的經濟其實非常非常差
就是那個我大概會給一點數據
可以自己
因為這裡畢竟是騰訊會
我不想講太多
但是可以給一點基本的數據
你們可以看一下中國經濟
其實情況還是非常不好
但是如果你看美國估值的話
就整體估值是這麼一個情況
就是我們看到幾
你不能跟20年比
因為20年是恩理下降導致的
現在整體的估值的趨勢就是偏高
但是半導體行業
我今天放在這裡放一個圖
也是說明這個問題
就是半導體行業是非常不同
所以回到整個市場來看的話
市場最近一段時間上漲
兩方面原因推動
第一個就是我們看到整體公司的盈利
公司盈利不光是在
半導體包括TSMC這些公司
它都medic expectation
而且給出不少的預期
金融公司的盈利也不錯
就是說包括JP Morgan和GovernsX
他們的業績都是不錯
所以就是一方面是業績推動
第二方面是我們叫做技術性的推動
技術推動
我們看到了去年類似的Vol
波動率的下降
比方說現在來看到的話
一個星期的波動率1.28
那麼Impliable 1.28
然後我們看到半導體的Vol
這個星期的Vol
Weekly的Vol
半導體的那些公司的Set
Vol可能是5.8萬多少
就整體看到Vixx在16
所以基本上看到波動率的下降
導致那些叫Systematic Position
Systematic Position就是包括CTA
包括Vol control
這些策略他們的買盤
都是相對來說比較多的
就是在過去我們說一個月
過去一個月
651global
那這個數據是S&P
但是全球化的話
不光是S&P
包括歐洲和中國加一項
香港和歐洲為主
加加日本
那麼Systematic Position
在過去一個月賣了670億美元
那麼pecifically
特殊的就是在上一週裡面
買了300億
那麼不光是這個情況
就是因為Vol在下降
它趨勢化的
會繼續要去買這個股票
就是它是跟著Vol下降的時候
它就會或者是走了比較穩定
繼續有上升的通道
它又會繼續去買
所以市場如果回持不變的話
下面一個星期
就接下去一個星期
它買420億
所以這個也是
就是說我們看到從頭寸上來說
或者是從整個趨勢跟蹤上來講
一方面就是趨勢跟蹤
變得更多的買路的時候
其實對市場是累加一個風險
就等於我吧
不停地加降
跟去年一樣
就累加一個風險
但是同時的話
會讓趨勢變得更加穩定
那麼接下去一個星期
可能要買42個別類
那麼第二方面的就是
我們看到美國的公司引力
是非常不錯的
我特殊說一下
就是銀行行業
因為有人正好問到過我這個問題
包括JP Morgan的業績
和Google的業績
我們怎麼看和結合後面
可能會發生的這個
deregulation的事情
第一個我覺得三個方面
就是第一個的就是
我們看到Long Demand
就是這個貸款的需求
在美國是上升了
這個是一個對於宏觀經濟面
宏觀經濟面非常不錯的事情
那麼貸款需求上升
那麼中間copper landing重新回升
這個從銀行層面來看宏觀經濟
第二個就是我們看到
從因為交易量在4月份是最大
那麼所以在我們叫Saleson Trading
像我們高層以前的這個政權部門
JP Morgan的 Trading部門
他們4月份的收益是很不錯的
就這個漲跌跟低了沒有關係
低了是希望交易量大
上下漲幅大
但是這個趨勢雖然4月份
叫5月份6月份
5月份6月份兩個月
他們雖然交易量下去
但是推定做的還是不錯
就是維持了4月份的趨勢
所以我們會看到
可能發生deregulation之後
投資銀行的交易會變得更好
08年之後
給了投往很多奇奇怪怪的規定
包括不能做很大的槓桿
那個甚至對於美國國債
都不能做很大的槓桿
導致我們以前的那種
就是readbook
就是我們的那個做利率的那些東西
必須減少投存
不許自己去押注
不許那個market maker去押注
那這些各種官洋規定
其實都是將低金融公司收益的
而且要求公清公司
有很大的資本金
那麼兩方面deregulation會發生
第一方面就是我們叫做
leverage就是槓桿
我們separmental leverage ratio
它的那個特別是對於風險低的資產
銀行對於低風險資產
一些槓桿要求會被放開
那這個之前我們說過
那個ESLR這個東西會放開
那麼第二方面就是secat會放開
就是銀行最低資本金的要求
就這個是相當於我們一類資本
原來叫一類資本
call capital ratio核心資本率
那大概資本率的放開
它會在80個basis point左右
就是整個銀行行業
所以第一方面
我對於低風險資產回放更高的觀感
第二方面就是
對於我們整個銀行的核心資本
充足率要求
可能會下漲
就整個資本充足率要求
可能會下漲80個basis point
就是對於風險類資本
就是我們叫respace capital
和non-respace capital
其實都會有放開
那麼銀行這個情況下
就會累積出更多的資本金
可以去做投資
然後銀行會累積出
這些資本金做投資
如果用不掉的錢
我覺得就是
因為它放開
可能是一字形的放開
那個包括ROM
就貸款和那個融資的需要
它是慢慢上去的
所以會有大量的多出剩餘的資本
資本金
那麼在銀行層面
可能會變成一個debitant
就是分紅
第二方面可能會變成回購
所以這個是推動這段時間
金融公司表現不錯
後來大家對金融公司
未來預期不錯的一個很重要原因
那麼銀行的業績中間
第三個方面就是我們看到
private side的需求也在上升
特別在美國
這個就在香港現在還沒有
就在其他rest of war
沒有很強的表現出來
確實中國把香港的市場炒起來
境外顯自有一半資金
全在香港炒股票
那麼就是為了把香港打開成
第二個融資的地方
但是畢竟香港這個市場
現在我們說為作為市場
因為我一直很看空中國的資產
港股確實漲了很多
但是我覺得它是一個不健全的漲
因為它沒有融資量的漲
就是跟美國的這個SNP是不一樣的
人家是有交易量
有價格
然後有融資量
就能夠重新融到錢
那在香港的話
現在融資再正在恢復
但是這個融資量
跟它現在這個漲幅並不成證據
就是並沒有出現大規模的
像19年以前
像大規模的發生的市場抽血
融資繼續上漲
這個沒有發生
就是乾炒
你就把它炒上去
然後希望能達到融資的效果
我覺得不一定會成功
那我說一下中國的情況吧
待會吧
那麼
所以Private side就是
融資方面在銀行層面
包括ECM這些
都是有不少的這個需求
所以這個是三個方面
就是對於對於銀行的業績
那麼銀行業績
其實是結合半導體的CAPEX來看
就是半導體的CAPEX
我覺得後面的需求還是會很大
那麼為什麼
我一直很看好半導體
我覺得半導體沒有問題的
最近一個新聞是說
GPT的需求大概是一個billion token
everyday
就是11個
billion
不是token
一個billion的那個請求
就是requirement everyday
那麼我們
我們原來的就是webserver
就是我們叫做webserver
就是網頁的訪問量的增加
是一個線性的增加
就是從其實從2014年到現在
沒有什麼增加
但是增加的話
它也是一個慢慢線性增加
因為這個東西
它是受限於你有多少人
有多少computing device
就是可計算的單元
比方說我多少台手機
我就能夠增加多少
那麼當你整個移動互聯網
差不多快保全球方面快飽和的時候
它的增加就是慢慢線性的
那個你一個人
不能夠同時拿五台手機
訪問不同的地方
但是從2014年23年之後
這個增加就變成非線性的
因為有更多的人會被轉化掉
就原來我是訪問網站
網頁訪問的
然後變成token訪問
變成那個influence的訪問
變成推理性的訪問
變成訪問GPT了
因為人困變得更懶
這個左邊那個圖
就是我們看到的這個search
網頁的search
下降的量
那這個下降量肯定不是人減少了
也不是說我的cabutin device減少
而是說這些的訪問量被轉化成為
A.I.類的訪問
變成你要說用了GPT
那你用一個GPT
用一次之後
它背後就你
我雖然我調用了一次
但是它這個計算並不是一次性的
它在那個雲端是要消耗很多token去計算
所以它變成兩個函數成起來
那麼整個token的使用量
我覺得就是一條指數的函數上升
那這個函數的上升
因為人只會變更懶
它不會變得更勤勞
當你的那個習慣了用
就是說A.I.類的這個回答以後
其實很多東西
它就不會再做research了
就好像我可以用谷歌以後
我就不會再回到圖書館去翻書了
對吧
一樣道理
所以這個我會感覺就是
整過什麼
我一直覺得半導體的業績是沒有問題
A.I.不是mapa7
更確定性的是半導體類
業績是沒有問題的
而且整個半導體是一個大周期
它屬於那個需求端的
就是供不應求的大周期
因為token的使用量指數級的在上升
token的價格還要還要
還要那個凡指數性的下降
然後你要更先進的東西
我必須要token價格要降下來
所以這三個函數等於成起來
因為我使用量
然後每一次調用要用更多token
token價格還要下降
那這個三個東西疊在一起
就是對於台積電就鋪面積了
對於台積電的這個產能有巨大的挑戰
就是我需要買更先進的芯片
更好芯片
然後更多的芯片
但是台積電的擴張
就是說現在你就說
整個市場上現在能產UV的產量的
這個公司只有台積電
那麼台積電的這個產量
它是線性擴張的
我到26年 27年 28年 29年
能夠鋪出多少產能
這是非常確定的
沒辦法擴張
那麼在這個過程裡面
就是大家會把所有產能全部施光
那最近大家看到一個公司
就不一樣說叫AMD
我忘了我上週有沒有講過這個問題
就AMD就是一個很很很克力的
很很明顯的一個事情
就是我只要有片
我就給它用掉
原來我們是覺得AMD的片
是ASIC用不了
推敵用不了
然後那個訓練用不了
但是問題是
我現在是只要有需求
只要能夠
你能夠有產出
所以我就能夠給你全部用掉
那麼這個
這個的結果就是
就是整個供不應求的市場
所以我們就覺得
就是銀行層面的這個Clapax
現在銀行層面的這個資本金的放換
其實同時的話
也會在未來一段時間反補
就是說我們現在要做的這種Clapax
很多公司層面的Clapax
包括半導體公司之類的
那麼這個是構成了
我覺得整體我最近一段時間
對美國的一個資本看法
就是整個資本市場的基本看法
US exceptionism
美國的特定性
美國的AI
AI的特定性是存在的
在半導體裡面相對來說
我覺得半導體大周期現在剛開始
但是整個美股的估值
在特朗普的關稅政策影響下面
關稅政策的影響逐步顯示的過程中間
它是會慢慢顯示
估值現在是偏高的
然後那個美聯儲主席換不換人
最終他的聯儲的這個政策
一定是跟宏觀基本面相關
它可以上來降以自息
但是它不可能配合你特朗普
去做到比亞索巴利西達的非常低
所以這些換不換人都是不太影響
就基本面
我們是處於一個
宏觀面並沒有那麼好
但是尾部風險變小
特定的Sector
特定的比亞索巴利西達
然後我覺得是表現非常好
所以也是這樣一個情況
那麼我過多說一下中國
我們剛剛講到三個方面
四個方面中間我去年講的是歐洲
那麼其實歐洲和中國是一回事
就是除了美國之外
經濟體最近具體表現怎麼樣
市場是把中國炒得很熱
香港我剛剛講
現在還沒有很大的融資功能
但是大家在說
中國國家增加消費
歐洲國家在做CAPEX做的軍費投資
那麼中國再增加消費
增加消費結果怎麼樣
我們出了表說拿5月份的數據來看
這是5月份上海的統計劇的數據
那麼5月份
那個2025年5月份
那個同比消費社會消費總額增加7.5
給你看看增加7.5
那麼1516
那麼去年5月份是1590
增加了7.5
我不知道這個7.5是怎麼算出來的
這個數字不知道怎麼算出來
但是實際的數字我們看到的是
在國家這麼多的消費支持政策下面
消費政策很難一直繼續維持下去的
上海下降了4.8
5月份
很久
就整5月份是下降4.8
那麼深圳和北京的公布是1到5月份
所以深圳是下降1到5月份
下降1.3
北京1到5月份下降2.8
這個是雪淋淋的數據
就是你真的花了錢下去
做了這個消費的支持
經濟在消費層面如此的下滑
還是這麼嚴重的下滑
那麼在下半年的時候
其實已經發令了
沒有去年9月份開始已經基本就貨幣了
已經看進去了
然後今年也開始直接發消費
就是國補已經開始做消費補助了
其實在這種情況下
經濟的消費層面有如此大的下滑
而且情況再變惡化
因為5月份的情況
比1到4月份更差
所以今年年底之前
中國要么就是更大程度上的印錢
那麼要不然的話
其實沒有辦法去對抗這個通脹
就是說中國一直想做一件事情叫什麼
叫做漲價去庫存
漲價去庫存在房地上已經幹過
這是不可能完成的
因為個人的資產負債表變差了
你現在在消費層面也想去漲價去庫存
就等於我發了錢
然後讓你們去消費
但問題是說
就像美國那邊是類似的情況
就是你希望把商品的價格炒上去
但是沒有辦法導致工資螺旋上升
就是跟當時德國以前的通脹人
完全找回事情
你工資螺旋上升不了
因為你產能過身
因為你沒有工作崗位
所以你的工資是上不去的
那麼你用漲價去庫存的辦法
我覺得很難完成
就基本面非常差
那麼從資本市場上來說
你可以炒一包
相反你現在可以在那裡拿保險公司的錢去惡炒
現在確實在這麼幹
但是最後結果會怎麼樣
我是騙悲觀的
我是對於這件事情騙悲觀
當你恢復融資功能之後
這個市場走到哪裡
那麼才是走到哪裡
我這個就是具體的數據
你反正深圳和北京數據
你們可以自己去統計劇的網站上看一下
因為國家已經不公布
很多項目的具體的數據已經不公布了
但是地方性的統計劇還是公布這些數據
你們可以去查一下地方的比方說
消費數據
查一下的地方的私營部門的固定資產投資
然後把今年數據和去年數據
這兩個原始數據要處於一比
在各個方面
每個城市的數據要處於一比
所以這個就是更加能夠清醒的認識到
現在中國大概是什麼情況
所以說如果說
整個經濟體有什麼風險的話
當然中國這個風險
並不一定會影響到全球市場
因為它是變得更捲
它變得更捲以後
反而壓低大家的物價
所以並不一定會影響到全球的市場
這麼更多的影響就是說
這個資金中國經濟差的時候
為什麼資本市場反而會好
因為它會印錢
然後炒資本市場炒熱
然後希望完成融資的功能
但是我覺得這個肯定不是一個能夠
sustain
能夠持久的一個事情
好吧
那個關於中國的事情
我可能不想講太多了
那我今天先講到這裡
然後看看你們有些什麼問題
然後我們Q&A一下